Freak bitches
now what about,
uh,
other kinds of therapy,
like a cold therapy,
ice bass,
cryotherapy,
things on those events.
Prolotherapy,
stem cell,
platelet injections.
If you could think of.
I've done it.
I wouldn't even get in.
I don't want your cat and your readers to hear everything I've done because they
would probably have me locked in.
Like what have you done that would have you locked up?
I've used our stint and strict nine injections.
What?
Strychnine strychnine or arsenic and strychnine try.
Why would they inject you with poison?
Because it raises your red blood cell count.
I've used nitric cushion cream,
natural glycerin cream because you know,
in a stimulate blood flow and me and start your heart up and I use it because I
broke my back and I didn't want to admit I broke my back a second time.
So I use it.
I told my friend who was a professor at Iowa state and says,
don't go nowhere to see what his dust.
I mean I was raised to beat for three hours.
I felt like you were hitting me in the head every,
every heartbeat.
Just hit me in a temple and uh,
so,
but I've done it all.
There's nothing I haven't tried.
I did lectric statement was,
it's called a microwave in linkedin up the muscles.
I'm Tom did it for what,
15 seconds?
I did it for 96 minutes.
What does it do?
It lengthens out the muscles.
Leary straighten out your leg right off the ground.
Electrocuting you and uh,
for six minute segments.
And I did 96 minutes.
So it's electrical muscular stimulation pads lengthens it.
So,
and I should never done it because I think I've got too many injuries,
you know.
And um,
it basically tore.
It popped my,
uh,
my hips and my children's out of socket
pop my hip bone right here.
My hipbone you're crazy.
Your whole body is like a walking medical encyclopedia,
you know,
you got to try it.
Right.
And that's me basically geeking out on the decks.
Yeah.
So,
and then Tony Trim,
which is a Dj that travels with him was like,
oh dude,
you can just get this and you can just buy this stuff.
And that's what really got me to do it was girl one up,
let's look at that white guy dance move.
We'll do that move.
You're doing there.
You're doing this.
Yeah.
Yeah,
that's true.
Just listening to you.
What really geeked me out.
But the name Dj Dad math came because he was becoming a father at the time and I
was like,
you're like way lane bro.
Me a dad.
And then it kind of morphed into Dj data are.
But taking it onto morning news was
funny.
That was so fun.
And I was like all the time,
you know.
So when you went on as a onetime goof,
did you have a plan or did you just not really.
I was just like,
the fun thing was to go was because I,
the thing that I hate the most we do.
They're like,
what can audiences expect this weekend?
They always say that,
oh,
I hate that.
And I'm like,
fucking show jokes.
What do you talk about?
Yeah,
what's,
what's bothering you right now,
Tom?
Yeah,
that's the setup.
Tell what's going on in your life and they think you just go there and then they
go,
just do whatever you want.
Like just have fun with it.
So when they do that I was just like,
it's not really,
I don't really give a fuck about comedy.
And then they were like,
what?
I'm like,
it's about the after party,
you know,
I'm gonna be deejaying and why I'm here.
Just to goof on them.
Like,
yeah,
because it was fun to have fun and be like,
all right,
you are at the funny bone.
Right?
I'm like,
I mean for a minute,
I don't even really care about it.
The funny bone.
And then you have the funny bone sitting right there off camera.
Like
who cares?
Like the best part is when he sets up like the really cheesy anchors to ask him
stupid questions.
Like did you,
oh you had someone do the bird is fat thing.
That was the best one because you know,
if you ever add sometimes when you go,
hey,
um,
you know,
asked me about farts or something,
they'll be like,
like,
so they,
they know not to.
They,
they,
they check themselves on asking something provocative or that's not 100 percent
pg,
so I didn't know how it would go,
but I go,
oh,
asked me my bird,
so fat and the lady goes,
okay,
and then so we just are in the middle of this interview
and she goes,
White Bird,
so fat.
And I was asked a good question and I'm like,
I just rolled with it,
you know,
and then it grew.
And then a hot dog eating champion,
a guy that was in Scotland,
she placed tinny place.
Yeah,
he's like one of the,
he was like a super competitive eater,
like a Kobiashi dude.
This guy was assigned to the audio on this.
It's incredible
life changing stuff.
Um,
I've dropped about 100 pounds in eight months.
He dropped 100 pounds my cheat day for the year,
but prepping just this amazing water which to giant inspirations first.
My wife second anniversary today.
So I want to say hi to her.
And um,
there's a comedian I love,
he's a big,
giant fat guy just like me,
Bert Chrysler,
he's still way bigger than I am.
Maybe I can inspire him.
We were talking about this woman,
we didn't talk about too much,
but we should.
This woman who was the woman that Hillary Clinton brought up during the trump
debate because she was saying that Donald Trump humiliated this woman because he
shamed her and humiliated her because she gained weight while she was a missile.
Olympia.
I miss this.
I was in the bathroom and you guys had this.
She got up to 170 pounds according to trump.
She went up from like 1:22,
one slash 70.
According to him,
probably not right.
Probably gained like 30 pounds.
But apparently she really did gain a fuckload of way.
And um,
and Hillary Clinton made this big deal about like how awful it was.
He did that to her and then they had these commercials already planned for the
next day.
So they launched these commercials the next day.
And in the commercials they show this woman,
she's speaking in Spanish.
You're talking about Donald trump is terrible.
What he do to me.
He made me feel bad.
He made me.
He was scared.
So then after that comes out,
people start researching her,
they find out that she drove a getaway car in a murder,
that she threatened to judge because the judge who is going after her boyfriend
at the time that she drove the getaway car,
she threatened the judge,
said that she was going to kill the judge.
She had an elite,
a illegitimate baby with a Mexican kingpin drug dealer.
All of the Mexican drug cartel kingpins came to the baby's Christening.
Then she went on,
big brother,
big brother.
She was engaged in some baseball player,
went on big brother and fuck some other guy on the show while the cameras were
on her and she was yelling out in Spanish that he has a magnificent coffee.
Wow.
The same lady that I used in our commercial.
So then they have her on CNN.
My.
So
Anderson Cooper interviews on CNN and Anderson Cooper says some people are
saying that you threatened to judge and that you drove a getaway car.
Like,
is this yours?
Everybody having pass.
Okay,
I'm not angel.
I'm not a bad person.
But they're trying to take away from what he did.
What he did was wrong.
Okay.
What I did was 20 years ago,
what he did was 20 years ago to all he did was coming,
but in his defense she probably was.
She got fat,
so there's pictures of her.
She definitely got fat,
but you know,
ordinarily that's a very rude thing to do,
but when your job is to be a professional hot chick,
it's like if you just decide,
say like if you're a model for like a shaving cream,
like have you like your,
your whole thing is about your legs and you're showing your legs.
I touched the mic,
sorry,
but your thing is about your sleek,
smooth legs and you're like,
fuck it.
I'm letting these bitches grow.
And everyone's like,
hey,
you can't do your job is to have sleek,
smooth legs.
No,
it's not that you're known for your nice flakes.
Yeah.
She's known for being a professional,
attractive woman.
Any holiday he shouldn't objectify women.
That is the whole point of being Muslim.
So Hillary paid her to obviously if she's in an anti trump commercial than that
means hillary paid her right.
Um,
might not be
money.
It might just be attention because it gave her the opportunity to get back in
the limelight and apparently she's a giant attention whore.
Gotcha.